sì perché lo fa discoteca the con dati
da questo after e poi su una prima
colazione perché ti pare che non
mangiavo che sto morendo di farne 9 e da
domani ti giuro ti racconto tutto adesso
voglio soltanto tipo morire nel letto
complimenti è brava brava mi sembra
questa l'ora di tornare 7 48 del mattino
ma tu sei pazza cosa sei una vagabonda
ma non so che non ho chiuso occhio tutta
la notte perché era un pensiero guarda
io te lo dico quando muoio poi fai
quello che vuoi ma finta e vidi sotto
questo tetto tu fai quello che ti dico
io e non tornare metti a quest'ora hai
capito che diavolo sono le avevo
lasciate qua sicuro mi saranno cadute
allora nessuno dove sono ma mai visto le
mie cuffie sono sparite non ne trovo più
sto cercando dappertutto ma solo la le
vedo con i miei occhi li sopra il tavolo
si sicietà ti devo portare da un
oculista ma non è possibile non c'erano
non trovi mai niente non sai cercare
[Musica]
mi sono una cosa che lui è stato ha
ridotti così perché piangi così ti ama
sentirsi mai fatto qualcosa
ma 18 nei racconti tutto perché io non
mi è mai e la mia bambina non si tocca
amore mio ti buonasera volevo ordinare
una pizza d'asporto allora si è doppio
mozzarella funghi il prosciutto e olive
e anche friarielli e anche di uster
monopoly può anche un cheeseburger se
possibile è una birra
non ho pure da 66 sì sì sì tutto per me
è sì capito in via si buonasera volevo
ordinare una pizza d'asporto
mi chiamo marina di avvio quel telefono
vi è poi la professionista della pizza
in casa lo vai a prendere da asporto
mamma mia faccia finta di non aver
sentito cosa vuoi dentro la pizza ti
metto tutto prosciutto mozzarella di
bufala e non parmigiano parmigiana
melanzane fritte peperoni quello che
vuoi basta che metti giù col telefono
[Musica]
invece sto guardando una serie tv
fichissima che è uscita da poco amo cioè
tra consiglio e bellissima giorno cioè
non riesco a smettere nome come quelli
si è capito che ti prendono e
assicurando una serie tv nuova
fighissima te la consiglio adesso ti
scrivo il titolo perché non me lo
ricordo
stavo guardando la serie tv cosa stai
facendo
senti scolta le sette losai e l'orario
della mia telenovela quindi adesso metto
qui me la guardo anche perché è stato
fernando io devo scoprirlo aver
accelerato lui e non sa conta tanto
giusto è stato con me resta coppa guerra
che ti piace seconda puntata poi i
presenti la sigla ma questa maglia nera
bianca ed è diventata minuscola ma cosa
se è possibile una volta a 40 gradi
mamma carico la lavatrice ferma lì te
l'ho detto mille volte marina ma guarda
stava lavando i colorati con i bianchi
con i delicati lei farà parte in acqua
fredda in acqua fredda try to mille
volte colorati ma guarda veramente vai
via faccio io
[Musica]